i want to tell everybody something about
your cable subscription that you may not
know now i'm not telling you what to do
here i'm not even sure what to do and
i'll tell you why this is a double-edged
sword but it's important that everybody
know
that if you have a cable tv subscription
with any of the major cable providers
you are paying fox news you are keeping
fox news afloat now it's a little bit
different when i say that you are
keeping fox news afloat than saying you
are keeping hgtv afloat or whatever the
case may be why is it different the
difference is that fox news specifically
mostly has deals with the large cable
providers that for each subscriber
they get a significant amount of revenue
typically almost two bucks a month so if
you have a cable subscription normal
cable subscription you never watch fox
news
you probably unbeknownst to you are
still sending fox news specifically
close to two dollars a month or close to
20 bucks per year now as we've said
before
fox news we've been talking about it all
week
numerous fox news hosts have been
perpetuating these ideas of so-called
great replacement theory or white
replacement theory it goes by both names
this was one of the undergirding
foundations of the buffalo shooters
manifesto and the buffalo shooter's
motivation for going out and seeking
black people to kill
okay
there's lots of other platforms that are
promoting this stuff as well the
difference is many of those other ones
are online so like for example some of
the people promoting white replacement
theory are on youtube and they make
money with ad revenue if you don't watch
them on youtube you're not giving them
any money great
the difference is that with your cable
subscription
even if you don't watch fox news you're
still giving them in many cases close to
two bucks a month now there's a website
i encourage you to check out called
unfoxmycablebox.com
and it number one tells you the full
scope of how fox news is funded in this
way and number two it allows you to tell
your cable provider to separate out fox
news to make it an optional channel on
just about every cable system you can't
say i don't want fox if you don't want
to pay for hbo on every cable system
that i'm aware of you just say i don't
want hbo great you don't get hbo and you
don't pay for hbo on most cable systems
you can't remove fox news and fox
business okay if you pay for for cable
or satellite tv you are subsidizing fox
news whether you watch it or not
the uh
the cable provider pays fox and they
pass the cost directly to you
now we've said before i've explained to
you fox doesn't depend that much on ad
revenue why not
because of these monthly fees from
subscribers when all of those
advertisers bailed on tucker carlson's
show and we watched an episode and we
saw that he had almost no advertisers
left and the advertisers he had left
were sort of like
low rent low low value kind of low brow
advertisers the mic pillows of the world
and stuff like that we laughed about it
and we had a grand old time but we
acknowledged that it doesn't really
matter that much because fox news's
revenue model two-thirds comes from
subscriber fees through cable providers
fox news makes close to two billion
dollars a year
from these hidden subscriber fees that's
twice what cnn makes and it's three
times as much as msnbc makes so sadly
all of our money if we have cable is
being used to fund this extremist
programming you should not be forced to
subsidize fox news but you don't have a
choice if you have a cable subscription
so check out unfox my cable box read
about it
fill it out which will send a message to
your cable provider telling them
separate this out a lot allow me to say
no
and that's what we really have to do i
mean obviously we can also cut the cord
the sad part about cutting the cord
while many people have done it and i
don't have any moral opposition to it
we we recently learned that thanks to
cord cutting
c-span which is a very valuable service
which has no ad revenue c-span has been
significantly hurt by cost cutting so
that's the tragic thing you might say
well i'll cut the cord to stop funding
fox great but then you also end up
hurting c-span which we don't want to
hurt c-span provides a valuable public
service so we have to pressure the cable
and satellite providers to stop
including fox news by default
you should be able to say i don't want
fox and if you don't want fox you
shouldn't have to pay for fox and the
cable provider shouldn't have to pay for
fox regardless that's the sort of system
that needs to be upended we're going to
keep you updated there's currently
negotiations actually happening right
now fox and cable providers are
negotiating their next contracts on this
on these subscriber fees and
we could really kneecap fox news it's
not a limitation on speech anybody who
wants to fund fox should be able to
anybody who wants to watch it should be
able to nobody should be silencing fox
fox can do whatever they want but
we shouldn't by default be paying for
fox news when we certainly don't watch
it and absolutely don't want to be
funding it we'll have more on this on
our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show